you know I'm just waiting for that
exchange of letters I'll be very
interested
um to see how the Prime Minister handles
this well let's just um I just want to
look in particular we've got Gavin
Williamson's letter here again and it's
what you touched on a little bit earlier
there Beth let's just go through it uh
so Gavin says as you know there's this
ongoing complaints process concerning
text messages I sent to a colleague I'm
complying with this process I've
apologized to the recipient for those
messages since then there have been
other allegations made about my past
conduct I refute the characterization of
these claims but I recognize they're
becoming a distraction for the good work
this government is doing for the British
people which we've discussed and and
this paragraph Beth I've therefore
decided to step back from government so
that I can comply fully with the
complaints process that is underway and
clear my name of any wrongdoing now now
step back is that some indication that
he thinks it's not all over because you
know way back what in the Blair
Administration we remember Peter
mandelson's second resignation then
there was an investigation which
actually cleared him but it was was too
far gone he didn't get back in until
Gordon Brown became prime minister
okay I think the thing about Governor
Williamson he was a former Chief whip he
has undoubtedly upset colleagues over
recent years but he's also proved for
those who he backs or supports quite an
effective operator which is why
different Prime Ministers put him into
jobs and into their cabinets
um
the question is he says he wants to
clear his name of any wrongdoing now
there's two complaints as I said
um I as I said I you know in terms of
the the former civil servant that that
person tonight saying that the actions
and words of Gavin Winston put this
person under acute mental health stress
um you know they are serious allegations
about
um what he allegedly said about telling
this person to Slit your throat and
throw yourself out of the window now if
there are other people that will back up
those claims and that you know is a very
very serious allegation and you know we
have seen situations where uh MPS have
been referred to the Parliamentary
Watchdog they have been found uh wanting
and they've been forced to to resign
from their jobs now Gavin Williamson's
clearly saying that I I need to step
back from government stop being a
distraction to the Prime Minister deal
with the allegations and as he says he
wants to clear his name of any
wrongdoing and that's uh that's what he
said I should say don't I've just had a
um a response from the cabinet from
Liberal Democrat Deputy leader Daisy
Cooper so this is what the lib dams have
said they said this should be the third
and final time Gavin Williamson is for
out of the cabinet Rishi sunak has
serious questions to answer about why he
appointed Gavin Williamson then stood by
him instead of sacking him his promise
to lead a government of Integrity has
been left in tatters we need to know now
that Rishi sunak knew about these
shocking allegations and went through a
full independent inquiry people deserve
much better than endless conservative
chaos that's the lib Dems so two things
there you know pointing to what you were
you know remarking on about circus
Dharma his promise to lead a government
of Integrity left in tatters the liberal
Democrats arguing they're now calling
for a full independent inquiry which is
also something that labor have asked for
an independent inquiry now I imagine
that number 10 will hope that the
resignation of Gavin Williamson from the
government and these ongoing
investigations
will be enough and I imagine that they
will not want to have to launch an
inquiry but as I said what is unclear
tonight is whether or not other
allegations
um will come out we should stress though
that Gavin Williamson
has robustly denied these allegations
and says he will clear his net and when
it comes to life to Wendy Morton
um the line from the government from
some of those sent out to sort of defend
the government or speak for the
government in the past couple of days
they've spoken about the difficult
relationship between the chief Whip and
some of the MPS around those difficult
times after Liz truss was elected as
prime minister but I but I have to say
I've also spoken to MPS that have said
to me uh that it's Brave of Wendy Morton
to stand up and speak out to against a
colleague that a couple of people have
said to me separately you know have
upset a lot of a lot of people in their
time as a parliamentarian so Gavin
Williamson a very divisive figure within
the Parliamentary party in which you
seen that deciding that he clearly
doesn't need him as a distraction in his
administration right now okay well let's
get some thanks for that Beth let's get
some reaction now from well a former
colleague of uh of Gavin Williamson sir
Anna subrier joins me now and Anna
Sudbury of course some you were in
Parliament weren't you the first time
that uh Gavin Williamson lost his job
when he was sacked by Theresa May as
defense secretary do you think after
that he should never have been allowed
back in as education secretary or into
Rishi sunak's cabinet
yes absolutely because look at the
reasons why Theresa May felt that she
had second was because he was meant to
have leaked um highly sensitive secret
documents which he should never have
done I know he denied it but he finally
went uh and I don't think that Theresa
May messed about if I may say
um she she acted quite properly and it
was we were astonished I think last last
people were astonished he ever came back
into government he was appointed by
Boris Johnson of course he was education
secretary at the same time of course the
Rishi sunak was sitting in in the
cabinet office uh as as sorry in cabinet
as Chancellor witnessing Gavin
Williamson's appalling mismanagement
your viewers will remember of what
happened during covid and the lockdown
and all the Fiasco over the exams and
the results and Williamson was
responsible for that and finally he got
booted out by Boris Johnson but bringing
him back by Rishi Suna given that he
knew and Beth Rigby I nearly said as
ever is right but she is right as ever
Wendy Moore as ever as ever but she's
absolutely right as ever but Wendy
Morton showed real courage in making a
complaint about Williamson uh but sooner
and it does come down to the prime
minister in his judgment because he knew
that she had made an allegation against
him now vicious May well have not know
the content of the texts but somebody in
his team should have found out exactly
what was in those texts because if he's
trying to distance himself from the
horror show of Boris Johnson who amongst
his many other failings was incapable of
getting rid of people when they had
cocked up fouled up in whatever way it
might be and he hung on to them and he
stood by people I go in Madison and so
he goes on and so it goes on if he
wanted to be acting seen as acting with
Integrity this break from the past
should never have appointed Williamson
in the first place and people like Daisy
Cooper and no doubt you know from labor
party as well Daisy Cooper from the lib
Dems make the very good point that this
speech hugely about the Integrity of our
prime minister an Ever reappointing
Gavin Williamson and why Anna subi do
you think that Prime Ministers keep
appointing him is it that experience we
know as the chief whip with his
tarantula and all that that he knows he
knows where the bodies are buried he's
very useful particularly when you're
fighting internal leadership battles
I I mean to be honest with you it's lost
on me I mean I never had any Runnings
with him and as Ann Milton observed
tonight it might be because we're too
old and he can't be bothered with us but
but in all seriousness I never had any
difficulties with him maybe they've
given up on me I just don't know but
you're right and I can't and I'm sorry I
can't answer your question as to why on
Earth he was ever brought back in maybe
I don't know he delivers people that are
still loyal to him or as you say maybe
he does know uh certain where certain
bodies as we put is a barrier in other
words he knows where the filth is on
people or whether he just in beagles his
way into the good books of people and
and wish you soon thought that in order
to try and somehow bring the
conservative party together he'd go and
reappoint somebody as appalling as
Williamson who had abused
the former Chief with and the most
important way you can't argue with the
language that he used to Wendy Morton an
exchange I never see an exchange of
texts like that in any part of my life I
was extraordinary and and actually it's
extraordinary that Rishi tsuna didn't
boot him out as soon as he saw those
texts to Wendy Morton
um we can see her there I mean you did
you just you don't speak to people like
that it's appalling you imagine it in
your workplace or any your your views
but if it happened in their workplace
people would be out on their ear
extraordinary it does speak up volumes
about the terrible State the
conservative party is in I'm afraid give
me your thoughts about what it says
about the Judgment of the new prime
minister and not just then appointing
Gavin Williamson but also so I'm a
brother man that the Home Secretary who
resigned six days previously and more or
less been well had been sacked by the
previous prime minister what then does
it tell us about the prime minister's
judgment
exactly right what does it tell us and
I'm sorry to say I think it shows that
we're almost into Boris Johnson Mark II
I mean as you know I've returned to the
criminal bar right so I was in court
today talking to colleagues as one does
waiting for a case to get on yeah and
really sensible Ordinary People just you
know just watch politics out on the
corner of their eye Satan sub said to me
I want Earth did Sue Ella bother them
who was dismissed left her job as Home
Secretary because again she had she had
she had passed things on but she should
never have done she reached them in the
serial okay and so on and said she loses
her job and then six days later a new
prime minister
reappoints her and I tried to explain
well I can see the logic because sunak
needed her for the vote gear storm is
absolutely right when he says this he
needed her support to basically to see
off Boris Johnson and to deliver 20 or
30 votes but it will come back and bite
him look I think the country's crying
out not only for competence but also
integrity and which is soon that
promised us integrity and that was shown
just not to be there by the appointment
first of all of swelling and then the
appointment of Williamson and it was
then exacerbated of course when it came
out that this complaint had been made by
Wendy Morton's no dispute about what was
in the text but the
sowerman isn't going to stay and rightly
so because she's she's unfit for
National of this she was an appalling
attorney general she was an even worse
Home Secretary that continues I mean
she's making she's beginning to make
pretty Patel look like a small L zebra
it's extraordinary okay
because they want to bring Beth Rigby
back in it might be interesting to get
to you too uh chatting but Beth take on
that I mean that's very interesting
point on the Subaru made about the
country wanting some quality some
Integrity some stability but let me add
in there of course not just the country
let's remember the turmoil of the the
trusts and the quateng mini budget the
markets require the markets are watching
the United Kingdom at this very moment
so borrowing costs have come down
because they say okay the grown-ups are
back in charge this is being watched
just where it matters
um I I think the thing I would would say
about that and I I'd be interested to
hear what Anna thinks about this too is
that a lot has been put on to Rishi
sunak in terms of
from the conservative party hoping that
he can turn things around after the
Boris Johnson era and then the debacle
of the list trust Administration but you
have to remember that Rishi sunak has
been an MP for about seven years and
only in cabinet for three and he's
actually relatively politically
inexperienced and I think that some of
these and he has quite young team around
him as well and I I think that in some
of this some of these issues these
missteps that distract from what he is
trying to do
um are really hurting him when he stands
on the steps of Downing Street and says
I am going to have a government and I
quote these are his words Integrity
professionalism and accountability and
and to sort of set your stall on being
that prime minister and trying to break
from the past while putting two people
into your cabinet one of which you've
already lost and another that a number
of people and these are former cabinet
ministers and people in the home office
have told me is probably gonna have to
go that doesn't speak to your aims and
principles and then it speaks of people
not following through and he needs to
rebuild trust with the British people
and that is a problem yeah will you have
the time for that and the subri what's
your take on that and particular best
point about well you know the
inexperience of the Prime Minister you
know but not just as a as a PM but as an
MP
she's she's absolutely right so strip
away one's own views political views
right whether or not you agree with
Richardson and so on and so forth just
look at him in terms of his experience
and I have to say that has been one of
my for what it's worth but that's what
I've been one of my greatest fears about
him is that I don't doubt he's bright I
don't doubt actually he's got some good
ideas I mean we shouldn't run to brexite
here but that's not as I'm saying get
rid of the policies just look at the
person in the terms that Beth was
describing and she's absolutely spot on
he has only been involved in politics
but and in Parliament really for a very
short time and and I'm sure Beth's right
when she talks about the people around
him very inexperienced and especially in
this crisis and in particular then you
know later on that the crisis that the
conservative party is absolutely in the
demands of the British people as you've
identified what they want and whatever
your politics I'm afraid I think Rishi
tsuno is just not up to it because he
just doesn't have the experience that we
absolutely need and so
again for what it's worth I cannot see
how the conservative party is going to
win the next election and he's going to
go down in history as one of those who
healed in that event he won't be prime
minister uh he will no longer be leader
of the conservative party and his time
will have come far too soon
okay uh Anna thank you very much Anita
for that Anna subi they're Beth Rigby
you've got some breaking news I've
literally just had the letter from the
Prime Minister I'll read I haven't read
it yet myself uh this is from Rishi
sunak to Gavin Williamson he says thank
you for your resignation letter it is
with great sadness that I accept your
resignation I know your commitment to
successive conservative governments and
the party over the years has been
unwavering I support your decision to
step back and understand why you have
taken it I would like to thank you for
your personal support and loyalty I know
you will continue to represent your
constituents with diligence and care he
then finishes saying I want to express
my gratitude for the work you have done
for this government so that is Mr sunax
the prime minister's response to Gavin
Williamson making it quite clear there
that the decision of the resignation or
saying publicly the decision of the
resignation was Gavin Williams I support
your decision to step back it is with
great sadness I accept your resignation
I have to say and I don't know what Anna
Subaru thinks that I think it's with
great relief
accepts that resignation okay because
it's just an open wound for him if he'd
stayed in post I just want to bring in
the opposition response as well we've
had Labor's Deputy leader Angela Rayner
releasing this saying this is a damning
reflection of a weak prime minister
Rishi sunak appointed Gavin Williamson
with full knowledge of serious
allegations about his conduct and
repeatedly Express confidence in him
this is yet another example of Rishi
sunak's poor judgment and weak
leadership it is clear that he's Trapped
By The Grubby backroom deals he made to
dodge a vote and is incapable of putting
country before party as families
struggle during a cost of living crisis
made in Downing Street yet another Tory
government has descended in to chaos not
an explicit call though for a general
election but pretty much implied there
Anna subi just on the the Downing
streets statements and we we never
entirely know whether I mean the
question is whether he uh was pushed or
jumped but certainly if you take them at
face value Downing streets saying that
it was Gavin Williamson's decision to go
yeah and he should have sacked him
fishing soon actually as soon as Anne
Milton gave her interview and and made
the claims that she did
um I'm sure were absolutely true but I
really she soon actually should have he
should have sacked him and I think it
looks really bad and what Beth thinks
but I think it looks really bad when it
well that letter doesn't that well
should have sacked him and it looks like
he's saying oh you made the decision to
go but she soon actually made that well
you should have stacked him actually
after Wendy exchange of texts when that
came out and what do you make then what
do you make of Labor um Deputy leader
Angela Rayner there talking about grubby
back room deals sander the uh all the
problems been made in Downing Street
well I I I I think she's right actually
I mean I think I do think that about
similar badman and you can only come to
that conclusion in relation to Gavin
Williamson because she can't he wasn't
he wasn't appointed on his Merit given
that we see soon at the Saturn governor
in cabinet with him and seeing the
terrible State messy made when he was
education secretary it was kind of like
we all forget that he was education
secretary during the lockdowns and he
was useless and absolutely Dreadful and
that's why even Boris Johnson had to get
rid of it it must be bad if Boris
Johnson gets rid of you
let's Hannah simply thank you very very
much indeed Let's uh bring in Beth Rigby
again so um reaction to that letter
first of all from the response from
Downing Street to Gavin Williamson's
resignation and uh Labor's take on it
well labors take let me just find it
Derma if you give me a second
um I've we've got it got it yeah yeah um
this is from um Angie Rayner the deputy
leader of the labor party she has
described this as a damn in reflection
of a weak prime minister Rishi sunak
appointed Gavin Williamson with full
knowledge of serious allegations about
his conduct and repeatedly expressed
confidence in him uh the deputy labor
leader goes on to say this is another
example of Rishi sunak's poor judgment
and weak leadership she says it's clear
that he is trapped by The Grubby back
room deals he made to dodge a vote and
is incapable of putting country before
party as families struggle during a cost
of living crisis made in Downing Street
yet another Tory government has
descended into care so I have to say
to have to accept a resignation within
two weeks of becoming prime minister of
someone that you put into cabinet whilst
other colleagues in our public is saying
there was a live complaint from a former
cabinet minister uh against uh this
colleague at Labor going to make hay
with this aren't they because it it just
it it completely plays into
um
uh Kia stormers attack lines on the
conservative government now lacking
legitimacy and credibility and also
lacking integrity and that was of course
the millstone around the neck of Boris
Johnson that eventually forced him out
and now these questions you know are
being leveled at Rishi sunak who
promised this Fresh Start okay Beth will
hold it there I'm just going to go over
sir Gavin's letter one more time he said
Teresa's sonaki wrote to him as you know
there's an ongoing complaints process
concerning text messages I sent to a
colleague I'm complying with this
process and have apologized to the
recipient for those messages since then
there have been other allegations made
about my past conduct I refute the
characterization of these claims but I
recognize these are becoming a
distraction for the good work this
government is doing for the British
people he then goes on to say I've
decided to step back so I can comply
fully with the complaints process much
more on that coming right up with my
colleague Anna botting Anna
thank you good evening tonight's
breaking news then sir Gavin Williamson
has resigned shortly after a former
senior civil servant had made a formal
complaint about a comments that he had
told them to Slit your throat the
official added that his words and
actions had had an extreme impact on
their mental health well in his
resignation letter sir Gavin said he
refutes the characterization of these
claims but let's find out more to our
chief political correspondent John Craig
now and um pressure John had certainly
been building
by the hour really yes and of course the
primary soon act and particularly over
the fact that he was warned about the
text sir Gavin sent to uh Wendy Morton
by the former party chairman sir Jake
Berry the day before uh Mr sunaka
pointed uh Mr Sir gavina to his job in
the cabinet office so the allegation
will be that uh Mr sunac was Reckless or
simply didn't care about the allegations
and that he was rewarding a political
crony for helping him to become Prime
Minister and leader of the conservative
party and disregarding these very
serious allegations now Anna subri was
claiming a short time ago that Mr sunac
should have sacked sir Gavin at the
weekend when those rather offensive and
abusive texts were revealed in the
Sunday Times newspaper now what has
changed today we had a significant
change change in the attitude of 10
Downing Street this afternoon in the
official briefing for political
correspondence that was when number 10
said for the first time that the PM
might not wait until the outcome of
these inquiries the one by the um
the um independent complaints and
grievance system in Parliament which uh
Wendy Morton had gone to and also the
one that sir Jake Berry started inside
Tory HQ previously number 10 was saying
let's wait for the outcome of these
inquiries this afternoon we learned that
Mr sunaka decided he wasn't going to
wait and clearly there will be the
inevitable questions did he jump or was
he pushed well despite what the Mr Sir
Gavin says in his letter it's pretty
clear that the Prime Minister pushed him
he was always likely to be very
concerned about an onslaught he might
face from circus starmer at Prime
Minister's questions tomorrow at noon
remember last week sir Kia uh tormented
Mr sunac about his reappointment of
swella bravaman six days after she was
sacked by Liz truss for breaching the
ministerial code and a breach of
security all the signs were that circare
was going to go on the attack probably
also still talking about suela bravaman
but on the very serious allegations of
against sir Gavin so
clearly there have been discussions at
the highest level of governments and
it's beside been decided that sir Gavin
had to go it was an inevitable outcome
really given the fact that the
allegations kept piling up there was
must have been real concern that more
allegations would come out in the next
24 hours and also the number of official
inquiries was was piling up as well and
uh when sir Gavin says he'd become a
distraction well he certainly had
um but uh clearly Mr sunac has decided
uh given that pledge about uh
accountability and integrity better to
cast Mr Sir Gavin adrift now rather than
have this round drag on for days and
days and days but it's entirely possible
of course uh that swella bravaman is
still in trouble tonight in the House of
Commons there was a very ill-tempered
debate
um where labor were trying to force
publication of minutes emails and so on
about security concerns about swella
Brava now the government government won
that vote by 92 huge majority but labor
will keep pressing away at that as well
so the pressure is now really on Richie
sunac just two weeks after he became
prime minister he's made what many MPS
will regard
as a crass a crass and Reckless and
ill-advised appointment in bringing the
controversial sir Gavin Williamson back
into government given his terrible
record as a cabinet minister sacked from
the ministry of Defense after
allegations of leaking security Secrets
sacked from the education department for
bungling the exams and the presiding
over a fiasco over exams during the
pandemic
yes uh fair to say John two
controversial cabinet appointments one
has now gone uh this is the statement
then from CFM Williamson to the Prime
Minister Rishi sunaki said as you know
there is an ongoing process concerning
text messages I sent to a colleague I am
complying with this process and have
apologized to the recipient of those
messages since then there have been
other allegations made about my past
conduct I refute the characterization of
these claims but I recognize these are
becoming a distraction for the good work
this government is doing for the British
people I have therefore decided to step
back from government so that I can fully
comply with the complaints process that
is underway and clear my name of any
wrongdoing
and this is the response then from the
prime minister
thank you for your resignation letter it
is with great sadness that I accept your
resignation I know your commitment to
successive conservative governments and
the party over the years has been
unwavering I would like to thank you for
your personal support and loyalty I know
you will continue to represent your
constituents with the with diligence and
care I also want to express my gratitude
for the work you have done for this
government
well this is the statement from Angela
Rainer then the leopardy the labor
Deputy leader this is a damning
reflection of a weak prime minister
Rishi sunak appointed Gavin Williamson
with full knowledge of serious
allegations about his conduct and
repeatedly expressed confidence in him
this is yet another example of Rishi
sunak's poor judgment and weak
leadership it is clear that he is
trapped by The Grubby backroom deals he
made to dodge a vote and is incapable of
putting country before party as families
struggle during a cost of living crisis
made in Downing Street yet another Tory
government has descended in to chaos
typical perhaps John words there from
the opposition about these two
controversial appointments as we said
but just run through us if you can once
again the specifics of the allegations
against sir Gavin Williamson that has
led to this resignation they began at
the weekend with the disclosure in the
Sunday Times and the mail on Sunday uh
of very low worried offensive abusive
text that sir Gavin sent to Wendy Morton
a few weeks ago when he complained about
not being invited to the Queen's funeral
she replied well look we've only got a
limited number of tickets and they're
mostly for the cabinet and Senior
politicians and parliamentarians like
the father of the house so Peter
bottomley was mentioned the father of
the house now in those exchanges there
were all sorts of phrases like for
example
um don't forget I know how the system
works and also there's a price for
everything and he used four-letter words
in quite an abusive way and if you look
at the replies from Wendy Morton they're
quite restrained she comes across very
much as the innocent party in those
exchanges now the next allegation in the
times on Monday are concerned a female
MP and the claim that when he was Chief
whip he threatened to exposed do some
details about her private life when she
was criticizing the government
allegation number three was the
allegation from the former civil
servants at the ministry of defense that
Mr Williams Mr Williamson as he then was
when his defense secretary had said slit
your throat and jump out of the window
and as we've heard in that that former
civil servants uh statement tonight that
made him suffer mental health issues and
then he when he saw the uh the nature of
the text that or WhatsApp messages sir
Gavin sent to Wendy Morton that's what
prompted him
to go to the independent complaints and
Grievous system in Parliament now can I
just pick up on a few points from the
letters and also what Angela Rayner was
saying first of all two things emerge
really from uh sir Gavin's resignation
letter number one which we did not know
until now was that he has apologized to
Wendy Morton because earlier today there
were complaints from some of her friends
and allies that he had not bothered to
apologize well he says he has now
um secondly the point about clearing his
name well we've all been through
resignations of politicians in one
Scandal or another where they always say
I'm confident I'm going to clear my name
so that's a fairly standard response the
third point I'd make is that um in
Angela Rayner's statement where she
claims that Mr sunak appointed sir Gavin
in full knowledge of the allegations
well that will be disputed by number 10
and has been already she's referring
there to the disclosure at the weekend
that the day before Mr sunac appointed
sir Gavin to that job in the cabinet
office he was warned by uh sir Jake
Berry the outgoing party chairman uh
that there were these allegations now
number 10 has always insisted
um that Mr sunac was not aware of what
was in the text and he was not aware of
the full details of what um sir Gavin
had said to uh Wendy Morton in quite
abusive terms now whether you believe
that or not I mean it was all over the
Sunday papers it was reported all day on
Sky News and elsewhere so whilst uh uh
whilst uh the Prime Minister may not
have seen uh the tax I'm sure it's it's
inconceivable they weren't brought to
his attention now he will say he was
flying off to charmele's Sheikh uh but
uh that is a subject for uh for that is
the subject of dispute uh labor claimed
that he was made aware uh number 10
we'll probably say no he didn't know the
full details either way Mr sunac is left
looking uh as as though he's made really
bad judgment here by bringing back such
a controversial politician as uh sir
Gavin Williamson and the the as Angela
Angela rain is claiming of course it was
all part of a grubby deal we've heard
that phrase a lot from um Zakia starmer
over the past week it's a phrase he used
in the Commons last week where he was
talking about the prime minister's
reappointment of Suella bravaman the
claim the opposition are making is that
The Grubby deal was to stop Boris
Johnson's standing for the Tory
leadership and so that uh that Mr sunac
would have more or less a clear run for
the leadership as it turned out the
other candidate Penny Morton was nowhere
near getting enough no nominations now
Boris Johnson and his supporters have
since claimed that he got over a hundred
and he could have stood but decided not
to but that's The Grubby deal allegation
that labor are making obviously denied
by senior tories
thank you very much indeed uh yes uh
we'll get to more reaction certainly in
just a moment but first of all let's
hear now a response from labor from the
shadow leader of the House sangam
debonair
well it's right that he's resigned but
I'm afraid it doesn't end here because
this is just another example of Rishi
sunak's weak leadership and poor
judgment now he appointed Gavin
Williamson despite knowing the very
serious allegations about his conduct
and yet he repeatedly expressed full
confidence in him so I'm afraid to say
this is as I said another example of
that week leadership it's an example of
a man who's Trapped By The Grubby back
room deals that he had to make in order
to avoid a vote when he was going
through the leadership contest Rishi
sunak seems to me to be a man who's
incapable of putting country before
party and this is no this is a time when
millions of people up and down the
country are having to deal with the cost
of living crisis that was made in
Downing Street and yet here we are again
with yet another Tory government
descending into chaos he said he wants
to clear his name surely he should be
allowed to do that well that's what he
says he wants to do but this is a man
with a with a pattern of behavior we've
seen more than one person make
allegations about him in the last I
think 24 hours they've been serious
allegations and I think it's important
that we just focus on the fact that it
was Rishi sunak who despite the fact
that he knew about these allegations
decided to appoint him anyway now as I
said it's a pattern of behavior because
he also appointed Sue Ella bravaman just
the previous week only six days after
she herself resigned for breaking the
ministerial code by her own admission
about National Security this is the
partner behavior from a weak prime
minister it's not what we need in the
prime minister at a time of national
crisis I really urge Rishi sunak to
think again about whether or not he is
the right man to lead this country and I
of course would prefer to see kirst
armor in number 10 Downing Street and
giving us that strong leadership this
country so badly needs this has all
happened very quickly I mean we haven't
even had to wait for an investigation
before we've seen Gavin Williamson
resign that you must be pleased with
that well I think it's right that Gavin
Williamson has resigned but he shows
from his letter no signs of taking
responsibility for the consequences of
his own actions but the serious Point
here is that Rishi sunak seems to be
incapable of making strong decisions as
a prime minister this is someone who is
clearly incapable of putting country
before party appointing Gavin Williamson
despite knowing what he had what he was
alleged to have done that was a poor and
a weak move and as I said it's it's a
sign of grubby backroom deals which he
really I'm afraid ought to be ashamed of
it's time he put country before party
thanks
well let's bring her now the editor of
the Jewish Chronicle and political
commentator Jake Wallace Simons who
joins me now I mean politically this is
fascinating isn't it given this is the
third time that sir Gavin Williamson has
effectively been forced to leave the
cabinet you know everyone asking why was
he there what had he delivered to wish
you soon act's campaign had he been
agitating was he key in the agitation
against Boris Johnson you know what can
we surmise from uh from all of those
questions do you think well what we know
for sure is that he supported Rishi
sunak in both of his leadership attempts
so obviously I suppose where she would
have felt a sense that he had to repay
his loyalty in some way and indeed in
his letter to Governor Williamson after
his resignation he didn't mention his
loyalty and he thanked him for that but
there are also suspicions inside
Westminster that Gavin Williamson was
responsible for agitating against Liz
truss him and another uh ex-chief
ex-whip
um in the sort of effort to play the key
role in the to drive Liz trust from
office and that of course ended up very
well for Rishi sunak and so these are
you know both reasons why Rishi sunak
may have hesitated a bit too long so
that Gavin Williamson has resigned
rather than being sacked and I think
that this leaves Rishi sunak in a
position where he's starting to look a
little bit weak weak is a term that
labor has used several times about
Richard sunac they're trying to pin that
on him that he has a lack of leadership
that he's a weak leader with bad
judgment and so on and so forth I think
we look at this Through The Eyes of the
voter of the general public and what the
voter craves right now is a bit of
stability a bit of security and a bit of
professionalism and competence at the
top of government as we face this major
cost of living crisis going into the
winter and what the voters see is the
chaos of the Boris Johnson
Administration being replaced by a very
professional looking new prime minister
of course the Liz truss uh period we can
set to one side but the problem is that
they also see that in richardsonette's
cabinet are the same old faces on a
Merry-Go-Round coming round and round
again which is a problem that any
government would face after having been
in power for as long as the Tories have
and so the challenge for Rishi sudak has
always been to show uh clearly and um
and and powerfully that this is a new
era of Tory government a professional
and responsible era and he's struggling
now to show that given this uh Gavin
Williamson Scandal which has Echoes
after all of the Chris pincher Affair
under Boris Johnson
so so two key accusations then against
Rishi sunak I suppose are one you said
you were going to lead a government of
integrity and yet you bought this twice
sacked man back into your cabinet and
secondly you appointed him knowing full
well that there were accusations hanging
over him because we know that the
ex-conservative party chair Jake Berry
said that he had raised the matter with
Rishi sunak and his team that complaint
about Wendy Morton
um accusing sir Gavin of bullying and
intimidation on the 24th of October
Rishi sunak took over on the 25th
subsequently appointing sir Gavin well
yesterday we know that the Prime
Minister spokesman told reporters that
Mr sunac knew there was a disagreement
but he didn't know the substance of
messages until they were published in
the Sunday Times is that enough of a
defense on that second accusation
well it does start to feel a little bit
weak and again Richard Knight is acting
under the shadow of the Boris Johnson
years and so there are echoes of the
Chris pincher Affair there are also
Echoes In some ways of partygate with
Boris saying they didn't know about uh
them happening and you know the party's
happening and then finding out that we
found out that he did and he didn't and
he did and so that's the kind of weight
of expectation that Richard zulak is
having to deal with and the assumptions
he's having to try to dispel I think
that he can get a certain Distance by
saying that he didn't know the latest
ones but certainly Gavin Williamson has
been a very controversial politician
with a history of being sacked twice
from the cabinet the first time around
as defense secretary after alleged
allegations of security links leaks not
too dissimilar from those Sawyer
brothman uh resigned over and the second
time uh just at the end of the covert
period and after the debacle of the
exams during uh the lockdown experience
and so this was a known quantity you
know Gavin Williamson was a hand grenade
that was waiting to go off and music
certainly took a risk in appointing him
uh who was you know Gavin Williamson of
course was one of Rishi sunak's key
supporters took a risk in appointing him
and indeed supporting him even when
these allegations were beginning to come
out over the last few days and now it
does look like that hand grenade has
blown up in the prime minister's face
because rather than taking strong action
and and gripping this problem uh he has
been following and chasing after events
being forced to receive a resignation
and respond to it uh generously rather
than being proactive and sacking him at
the first opportunity
can I just ask you about the role of of
Chief whips because clearly Gavin
Williamson was a former Chief whip you
know they're known as masters of the
dark arts aren't they they know where
the bodies are buried does that go to
their heads do they just carry on living
that world you know becoming the
Rottweilers of political life from from
thenceforth
well I've got to say I mean looking at
the allegations against Gavin Williamson
um you know it does sort of match the
cliche of a cheese whip not only the
aggressive but shall we say style uh to
put it mildly uh but also the the
preoccupation with
Gathering Intelligence on people gaining
leverage over people for example you
know that that uh unfair you know
unproven story about him giving
financial support to an MP and then
saying that he uh he then owned that uh
MP these are all parts of the cliche of
the Dark Arts of the chief whip it's
almost like something out of Malcolm
Tucker from the from the thick of it you
know they'll be familiar to viewers
um and so I I do feel that in some ways
Gavin Williamson was the archetypical uh
Chief whip representative of a whole
breed of politician that does indulge in
these dark arts and is known for their
effectiveness in in whipping MPS to tow
the party line and so in some ways you
could say that Gavin Williamson you know
maybe overset the mark a bit but he
didn't behave you know that differently
from how one might expect the chief
whips to behave but as Boris Johnson
famously says in his resignation speech
when the herd moves it moves and when
somebody begins to receive bad headlines
and their support base begins to crumble
than the sharks that have been circling
the enemies that he would have made many
many element enemies over his time in
Parliament since 2010 when he was
elected under David Cameron don't forget
which is a long period
um those enemies will come for him and
it looks like they're going to escape
tonight
well assignments thank you very much
dude absolutely fascinating isn't it
turned let's bring in now a journalist
and author Christina Patterson and um
you know it is fascinating because
anybody who'd hoped for calm and
stability in political life after the
brief Liz truss era um you know that's
falling by the wayside fairly rapidly
isn't it first of all those issues
around Suella bravaman and Asylum claims
and now obviously sir Gavin Williamson
Christina
well I mean there was a I feel an idiot
actually uh because there was a moment
when Rishi sulat gave his speech on the
steps of dining Street there aren't
actually steps in down the street but
that's the cliche that's always used
after the uh the the sort of mass trauma
really of the brief truss era and the
incredible damage he managed to uh
unleash on the nation and when he talked
about public service and putting country
first and all of these things I was
crazy enough to believe him when he
talked about integrity I thought oh
maybe he will restore a bit of
professionalism and integrity as he said
he would well of course all of that very
quickly unraveled first of all with the
appointment of Zoella bravaman and who
had just been sacked or resigned uh six
days before and who seems to have been a
Serial breaker of
um the uh ministerial code uh I mean you
know she claimed it was that she made a
mistake well she repeatedly made that
mistake and as
um the kind of Chief legal officer for
the nation formerly she can't have been
a surprise to her that you're not
allowed to use personal emails so that
was bad enough and as we know that she
has continued to be mired in controversy
and
um there are lots of assertions that she
has been repeatedly warned
um that she's been breaking the law in
ignoring the legal advice in relation to
the um Asylum Seekers uh on the coast so
I mean that she is still in post and I
think she is I mean if anyone was ever
less worthy of a title like sir I can't
really imagine it because it is very
clear and has been clear for a long time
but he is was not only the worst
education secretary probably in history
but is a very very nasty piece of work
has any of us ever used language like
that in relation to a colleague whatever
you think of the chief whips Wendy's a
former Chief whips
um the way that she has done her job
nobody deserves to be spoken to in the
way that he spoke to her in those
WhatsApp messages it was threatening it
was it was deeply deeply nasty and the
idea in his letter that he can say that
he thinks
um his comments have been misconstrued
you don't tell someone to Slit their
throat and jump out of a window and then
laugh it off and say oh no no no I was
just having a joke so I mean of course
he had to go but Rishi soon acts
judgment in appointing him
I mean you have to think this man he was
mad he was absolutely mad we know what
he was trying to do it was very clear
that he felt he was he felt he couldn't
afford not to have him in the cabinet
because of the uh debt he owed him for
his so-called loyalty or let's just say
Allegiance at that particular moment
because none of these people appear to
be loyal to anyone individual but to
talk about integrity and then take into
your cabinet someone who you have just
been warned is under investigation it's
breathtaking really breathtaking
well the um the SMP are not using the
word sir which you took such offense to
um the deputy leader at Westminster
Kirsten Oswald said the fact that Gavin
Williamson was allowed to resign after a
Litany of scandals rather than be sacked
speaks volumes of how toxic and broken
this Tory government is and certainly
the excitation against Liz trust was
that she had rewarded allies and
supporters those who believed in her her
political cause and the Hope was that
Rishi sunak would not do you think in
this appointment
um in your view he has failed in in that
ambition
absolutely I mean to be fair to Rishi
sunak he he has not appointed a cabinet
entirely made up of loyalists in the way
that both Liz truss and Boris Johnson
did because he is aware that one of the
biggest challenges facing him apart from
the 50 billion hole in the uh in the
public finances is that he he knows he
has to try to unify a party that is
absolutely Riven with um Strife at the
moment and I presume that Zoella
bravaman and Gavin Williamson were
attempts to bring in different parts of
the party but absolutely uh you know to
to talk about integrity when you have
appointed people who whose Behavior
Falls so very short of what anyone would
regard as normal behavior in any office
can you imagine anyone any manager
getting away with the kind of comments
that he made in in those WhatsApp
messages I think it's breathtaking
taking so absolutely I think it's a
major sign not just of weakness for
Rishi sunlight but actually of
incompetence and as Angela Rayner has
said of grubby deals because that's what
it's what it smacks of
well generic of the eye has um has
tweeted this evening that Gavin
Williamson's resignation means that now
a total of 80 ministers or whips have
resigned or been sacked from the
government since the start of 2022 we
knew we were living through a period of
political turbulence but that kind of
underlines it doesn't it it's it's
incredible I mean you can barely keep up
with who's prime minister but when you
think of all the people who resigned in
the last days of Boris Johnson and and
now they say I don't think we've ever
seen a period of instability like this
and I think everybody's sick of it I
mean Rishi sunak was meant to be
bringing in a degree of stability what
he should have done clearly was hold an
election I think everybody was sick of
the of just the the drama actually I
think what we all want is less drama in
politics and well good luck with that
because we've already got this drama and
then no doubt the suela brabhaman drama
will go on and on and I can't see I
can't see that we will have a period of
stability now and then you know the next
thing we'll be getting the legislation
through the House of Commons and some of
the cuts will no doubt be controversial
some of the tax Rises that are raised in
Jeremy Hunt's Budget on the 17th of
November none of this is going to be
easy stuff so it's been really I think
we can wave goodbye to stability but I
think what we would all really like is
not just less drama and less excitement
but actually some kind of proper
behavior the kind of behavior that we
are all expected to do in our workplaces
to treat people actually with respect I
don't think any of us I mean you know I
worked on Fleet Street for years or it's
modern equivalence and we didn't use
language like that to each other and
it's famously a testosterone-fueled
environment so I think people would find
it pretty shocking that this seems to be
kind of common parlance in politics
these days
fascinating here to hear from you
Christina thank you very much indeed
well let's just bring you tonight's
breaking news then so Gavin Williamson
has resigned shortly after a former
senior civil servant made a formal
complaint about comments that he had
told them to Slit your throat the
official added that his words and
actions had had an extreme impact on
their mental health in his resignation
letter sir Gavin said he refuted the
characterizations of those claims as you
know there is an ongoing process
concerning text messages I sent to a
colleague this is the letter he wrote to
the Prime Minister I am complying with
this process and have apologized to the
recipient of those messages since then
there have been other allegations made
about my past conduct I refute the
characterization of these claims but I
recognize these are becoming a
distraction for the good work this
government is doing for the British
people I have therefore decided to step
back from government so that I can fully
comply with the complaints process that
is underway and clear my name of any
wrong doing
and this is the response of the Prime
Minister then thank you for your letter
your resignation letter rather it is
with great sadness that I accept your
resignation I know your commitment to
successive conservative governments and
the party over the years has been
unwavering I'd like to thank you for
your personal support and loyalty I know
you will continue to represent your
constituents with diligence and care I
also want to express my gratitude for
the work you have done for this
government let's get more reaction join
him in here now is the chief leader
writer at The Observer Sonia soda and
has he gone quickly enough Sonia to
protect the reputation of the Prime
Minister
I don't think so I think for two reasons
uh the first is that Rishi sunak
appointed him to the cabinet even though
he was apparently informed about some of
the bullying allegations very serious
bullying allegations against Gavin
Williamson so I think that raises
questions about Gavin Williamson's
conduct and judgment
scenic's judgment rather that aren't
going to go away just because Williamson
has now resigned and then the other
thing is is that it it was Williamston
who resigned it wasn't where she soon
act sort of sacking him and there's a
good argument that actually Rishi sunak
should have acted to force him out of
the cabinet as soon as some of these
Revelations came to light and in fact
we've seen more and more Revelations
over the last kind of um few days more
and more allegations building up not
just from the former Chief whip Wendy
Morton but from an unnamed female
conservative MP who says that um you
know Gavin Williamson essentially she
took it as a threatened threat to reveal
stuff about her private life but because
it's a campaigning that she was doing
and then we've got these very very
serious allegations by Ministry of
Defense civil servant
Angel Arena Deputy labor leader talking
about grubby back room deals bringing
some of these people into cabinet you
know we want to know don't we why sir
Kevin Williamson was appointed and what
was done to bring swella bravman back as
well was it this desperation to avoid
another leadership contest to take it to
the party which certainly some members
of the conservative party were very keen
to see happen well I think there's
probably a couple of things going on so
with sowella bravaman who uh Rishi sunak
appointed to Cabinet despite the fact
that she resigned six days earlier for
breaking the ministerial code
um most people think that that was about
the fact that he had to strike a deal
with her in order to get her support
make sure he had the support of enough
MPS to essentially keep others off the
ballot paper and ensure that the
Premiership was his and I think there's
a there's a lot in that with Gavin
William said I think it's something
different Gavin Williamson has long been
loyal to Rishi sunac he supported both
of his leadership bids that we've seen
this year and so I I expect that Cenac I
mean it's clear that he was aware of
some of the allegations against
Williamson but what it looks like is
that he just thought well I've got to
have this man by my side anyway because
of what he can do for me to the migrant
crisis Home Secretary um
oh sorry answer Gavin Williamson um you
know one is gone it was all about
unifying the cabinet unlike you know the
complaint about Liz truss who rewarded
her supporters and so on you know did he
do the right thing to get a broad Church
of the party is that what was required
or did he just need to steer clear of
all political difficulties well I think
there's a broad church and then I think
there's appointing people who face very
bullying uh very serious bullying
allegations to your cabinet and the the
the really worrying thing about this is
it it says that Rishi soon is a prime
minister who basically says oh well you
know someone's very serious allegations
against someone and it's a kind of an
Open Secret Westminster that these are
the sorts of tactics that Williams and
news is he's not a very pleasant
individual but I'm going to sort of
weigh that against other things that he
can do for me and of course that is
absolutely not the right way to regard
allegations of bullying and harassment
they are never okay and they aren't
canceled out by other things that can go
into the political equation so I think
that's what's so troubling about this
and I think it shows how how what a
tight spot where she's seen that was in
actually he's wanted to portray himself
as a fresh start for the conservative
party and some of your other guests have
been saying but the fact that he's had
to pack his cabinet with Sue Ella
braveman you know resigned six days
earlier for breaking the ministerial
code Gavin Williamson sacked from two
big jobs in cabinet already for some
pretty disastrous conduct in those jobs
um you know really incompetent military
defense and at the DFE and then you're
having to bring him back I just think it
speaks to a conservative party that is
sort of heading towards the end of days
in terms of its electoral fortunes
thank you very much indeed Sonia soda
there let's return to our chief
political correspondent
um John Craig now um you know this era
of calm that people had hoped for with
the Rishi sunat government you know
filled with Asylum issues in Kent with
now with these allegations that had been
mounting against sir Gavin Williamson
how distressed will number 10 Downing
Street be at the turn of events of the
last couple of weeks John well the
traumas and the problems are all
self-inflicted he didn't have to
reappoint swella bravaman that was a
gamble a massive risk and that arguably
has backfired and he didn't really have
to bring back Gavin Williamson nobody
would have complained if he hadn't
brought Gavin Williamson back it was
clearly uh rewarding a political crony
for help that he'd given him in his bid
to become leader of the party uh so uh
he can I mean his critics will say this
is all his own fault
um the two things spring to mind also
just on the letter from Sir Gavin just
reading it again he says I refute the
characterization of these claims he
doesn't say I refute the claims he says
I refute the characterization of the
claims in other words uh the way they've
been reported so he's not actually
specifically denying the allegations and
talking of allegations there are there
have been some more this evening from
Anne Milton a former whip deputy chief
whip at one stage she said in an
interview tonight that he used unethical
and immoral behavior
um they she's talking about a time he
helped they helped out a Tory MP in
financial trouble and she said I do
remember him asking me to give the MP in
question the check and he waved it under
my nose and said make sure when you give
him the check he knows now I own him and
on another occasion
um
he let rip over an email when a female
civil servant asked why ministers uh
travel plans had changed and there was
also um
um he she said he relished in learning
salacious gossip including the sexual
preferences of politicians and another
claim that um uh about an MP who had a
drink problem
um that um he used that for political
game as well again as well for them and
didn't do the that MP any favors at all
so more and more allegations about the
way he operated as Chief whip in
particular also as um as defense
secretary are emerging by the hour
really and it was only after I think Ann
Milton was speaking uh
um in an interview that his resignation
came now some Old-Timers will probably
say oh the whips office has always been
like that there's always been bullying
and threats and so on but the sort of
stories we're hearing about Sir Gavin
are do go rather further than the old
days of uh Chief whips and other whips
shouting at uh at MPS we're talking with
threats and all sorts of uh generally
quite unpleasant behavior and I think a
lot of people at the weekend were
absolutely appalled by the language he
used to uh Wendy Morton there have even
been claims that sir Gavin didn't
approve of Liz truss appointing a female
Chief whip
um I'm not sure about that but uh he
clearly um he was arrogant the tone of
his text to Wendy Morton was nothing
short of arrogant uh basically saying
look I know how the system works and so
on and uh and also I mean it to try and
claim that he should get an invitation
to the Queen's funeral when it was
blatantly obvious that there were only
going to be a limited number for
politicians and at the time he was a
backbencher so he a lot of people will
say he's behaved appallingly and he
deserves to be out of the government and
they will also say she'd never been
brought back now let's look forward to
prime minister's questions tomorrow at
noon
um we often say don't we plenty of open
goals for us sirma I mean last week he
was very
forensic and used his former DPP style
and in the questions about suela
bravaman
um I suspect we'll hear more about Sue
Ella bravaman from Cirque tomorrow but
also he will say that sir Gavin has done
the right thing by resigning but he will
hone in no doubt on that point that
Angela Rayner has referred to about Mr
sunac knowing about the allegations
about the Wendy uh Morton text the day
before he appointed sir Gavin Williamson
so
even though Mr sunac will hope to say
okay look I've dealt with that he's
resigned the opposition uh whether it's
both the the labor party the liberal
Democrats the SMP will really go for Mr
sunac in what is it second or third pmqs
is it's I think it's the third isn't it
um and uh what are two weeks we've had I
mean that Mr sunac only became prime
minister two weeks ago today
and we've already seen his first
resignation and it's worth pointing out
that sir Gavin is now lost his job in
the cabinet or attending cabinet and uh
three prime ministers uh Theresa May
Boris Johnson and um and now uh Mr sunac
and and it it is as others have pointed
out this evening all very messy and
chaotic and it's not a great start for
Mr sunak I mean he he will regard his
meeting with President macron uh this
week as a success because he hopes to
make progress on the really trouble
troubling and Troublesome issue of the
migrant Crossings in the channel and he
no doubt will have come back from uh
charmel Sheikh uh quite relieved that
that went well but he's been plunged
into this political crisis as soon as he
got back and uh tomorrow I predict he's
in for a pretty Torrid time at Prime
Minister's questions
yes and on that issue of he was warned
um the PM spokesman I think yesterday
John I don't even know if you were there
uh saying that Mr sunak had known there
was a disagreement but he didn't know
the substance of the messages until he'd
read about it in the uh in the Sunday
Times in the weekend papers but given
the accusation of weakness uh towards
which is unique from the opposition
where does that leave swella brothman
then does it leave her less secure do
you think well she of course is
vulnerable to any more disclosures uh
that uh might come out about uh her
breaches of a breach of security when
she censor the uh email the document to
uh the Tory MP Sir John Hayes from her
own private account also in its uh
motion it's in its motion tonight the
labor party where the labor party lost
the vote by 92. labor let me tell you
what labor are trying to uh to get
um they're talking about exceptional
security concerns they're saying was
there any risk assess
by the cabinet office or the prime
minister's office relating to her
appointment any documents at all any
security breaches any leak inquiries and
that labor were calling for publication
of the minutes
um of meetings electronic communications
I assume that means emails in the
cabinet office or the PM's office
relating to the appointment and they
were calling for some material if it was
redacted to be handed over to the
intelligence and security committee
which of course is an all-party
committee so labor will no doubt keep
probing away at that even though that
they've lost the vote tonight on that
the Prime Minister I guess will be
determined to hold on to swella bravam
and having lost one a valued member of
his government there were those who said
that uh Mr Mr Gavin had a non-job what
is what is the what is the Minister of
State in the cabinet office do well in
fact we learned today what his
responsibilities were security was one
of them Communications was another one
um it's it's not the most high profile
job minister of State the cabin office
even if you're attending cabinet it's
essentially an enforcer and a fixer
doing fixing for the prime minister no
doubt with civil servants with MPS and
given that that was the role the
accusations of bullying of course are
all the more serious so um the the um
the Home Secretary isn't out of trouble
yet I mean if she faces more allegations
or more disclosures for example from
inside the home office from disgruntled
civil servants then she could be plunged
back into trouble
um the uh it's often it's been suggested
over the past week or so that Robert
generic's been put in the home office as
immigration Minister he's sort of on the
subs bench ready to step up to Home
Secretary if she has to go
um so um there obviously are some
concerns about swella bravaman's
position she Delights plenty of Tory
back benches as we've seen with her
tough talk on immigration you remember
that controversial phrase she used last
week an invasion on the south coast well
some Tory MPS love that others were
absolutely horrified by it
yes and some said it was a wonderful
distraction uh to what was happening at
that Manson Refugee processing center
John
um that's uh thank you very much indeed
for that stay there lots more to come uh
we will hear again though from labor
um they've said the episode is a damning
reflection of a weak prime minister here
then is the shadow leader of the House
thangam debonair
well I think it's right that Gavin
Williamson has resigned but he shows
from his letter no signs of taking
responsibility for the consequences of
his own actions but the serious Point
here is that Rishi sunak seems to be
incapable of making strong decisions as
a prime minister this is someone who is
clearly incapable of putting country
before party appointing Gavin Williamson
despite knowing what he had what he was
alleged to have done that was a poor and
a weak move and as I said it's it's a
sign of grubby back room deals which he
really I'm afraid ought to be ashamed of
it's time he put country before party
or joining me now is the economist at
the article Ali Mirage um good to see
you well Liz truss's mini budget was a
self-inflicted wound we all see now and
John Craig's um suggesting there that
actually the difficulties of Rishi
sunak's government in the last couple of
weeks is also self-inflicted because he
did not need to appoint solubman or sir
Gavin Williamson
um do you agree
well and he's got a very difficult job
he came in in very difficult
circumstances and he's got a party that
is in part ungovernable and is
completely factionalized and he knows
that and he admitted almost as much when
kirstama asked him at Prime Minister's
questions uh you know why he had
appointed to an abroad when he said I'm
bringing Unity uh to this government and
he was actually being truthful he is
trying to bring Unity which is very very
difficult I mean the thing that strikes
me about this is You've Got Jake Berry
the former Chief whip now a a Liz
trussite and you've got Wendy Morton the
former Chief wit sort of talking about
this in public it shows to me that the
Tory party is being very ill-disciplined
at the moment and again Riven with
factions and infighting and quite happy
to do this in public I mean the very
thought personally of being uh
intimidated by Gavin Williams it makes
me a little bit uh sort of I find it
slightly amusing I mean I speak to one
MP at the time he was uh facing all his
problems as education secretary saying
that he was the Frank Spencer I quote of
British politics and anyone by the way
who thinks that but I'm not excusing
what he did with Wendy Morton by the way
or indeed with a civil servant which I
think was a lot worse I mean those are
allegations they're being investigated
so he will obviously have a right of
reply but he's not denied saying that
the person should jump out of the window
or slit their throat I mean you can't be
using language like that with your
officials um but when it comes to Wendy
Morton again I don't defend the language
that was used but anyone knows that
politics is a rough and tumble brutal
ruthless business anyone with an
elementary understanding of having
watched House of Cards either the
original UK version with Francis Zircon
or the US one will know that whips and
all the things they do and Gavin
Williamson let's not forget was a former
whip our nasty pieces of work uh their
job is to impose discipline I remember
when I was standing as a candidate they
tried to impose discipline all the time
and I told them where to go on the Iraq
War for example so you know look I'm not
excusing any of the language that he's
particularly with the civil servant but
you know it's a rough and tumble world
it's a nasty business if anyone on
things politics is like a normal
workplace they're living in Cloud Cuckoo
now I mean maybe it should be but it
certainly isn't
well one one you know is it any defense
to talk to your colleagues like that if
you're chief Whip or not and secondly
you know he wasn't Chief why continue to
act as if he was no you're right I mean
look it's not the right kind of language
you should be uh using language like
that very aggressive uh swear words with
your colleagues but look if anyone
thinks I mean he should apologize and I
think that would have been a noble
circumstance it would have been done and
dusted the very fact that Wendy Morton's
bringing this up now and is potentially
wanting to have this investigated to me
shows a bigger issue which is not just
the language here and the fact that
she's offended fair enough normally this
would have been handled behind closed
doors he would have been slapped on the
wrist they would have had a coffee she
would he would have apologized to her
and it would have been done and dealt
with the issue here is and this is the
problem for Richard who by the way I
have a lot of time for I think he's a
serious figure I think he's got a
serious Chancellor and the adults are
back in the room and they've got a
really tough business job to do
particularly on November the 17th or
that economic statement they don't mean
this is a distraction it's like a hole
in the head he's got a really tough job
to do and what this shows to me is the
conservative party is ill-discipline and
it shows what a difficult job Rishi
sunak despite his uh many attributes and
I I really wish him well and I want him
to do well for the country he's got a
really tough job to do managing his
party right now
I'm edged
sunak that is
sorry sorry is he damaged
no I don't think we
think Rich look it's unhelpful but as I
say that if he had complete carte
blanche Anna and indeed if he had
actually won that leadership election
outright in the summer and the members
had not gone off in a tangent and made a
mistake by winning police trust and they
voted him in I think he would have had a
stronger hand to play than he did I mean
look he was coming in in really
difficult circumstances without a
membership vote he's well aware of that
he's coming by acclamation by MPS he's
got a still a very factionalized party I
mean almost 100 of them supposedly were
led to believe we're going to support
Boris Johnson I mean I can't understand
why but anyway that's another thing a
lot we're going to support penny more
than he understands all this he's a
pragmatist he's a serious figure he's
got a difficult job to do his focus is
at the moment on trying to get the
country in some sort of economic shape
restoring confidence in the markets was
absolutely shattered in the last few
weeks uh he's gone to charmel Sheikh
he's uh trying to make a deal with the
the French on the migration crisis the
man has got problems coming out of his
ears he's a serious figure he's got a
serious Chancellor you should be allowed
to get on with a job and frankly I think
Gavin Williamson to be fair to him has
done the right thing by resigning before
he was probably pushed because it is
distracting the government and look
Gavin Williamson was sacked as education
secretary he was also sectors defense
secretary
um so look I think Gavin Williams has
done the right thing by the government
but I mean look I don't think uh Rishi
sonnet can afford many more of these but
this is a distraction from the serious
business of government and by the way
Anna let's not forget that there is a a
wider issue potentially of bullying
within politics and within sections of
the Tory party I mean it was only
um a little while ago that pretty Patel
was also investigating for bullying when
she was Home Secretary resulting in a
report conducted by Alex Allen uh the
independent advisor on the ministerial
code who resigned on the back of uh the
prime minister at the time Boris Johnson
taking absolutely no disciplinary action
at all against pretty Patel so whilst I
think most MPS and ministers really do a
good job under difficult circumstances
working long hours and trying to do the
best for their constituents in their
country there are some rotten apples
that need to be rooted out uh in the um
in and around Westminster that throw
their weight around but that has always
been the way I mean in my experience of
politics it's a brutal Rough and Tumble
business it is unfortunately not like a
normal place of work and I doubt that it
ever will be
Ali thank you very much lead Ali Mirage
there so let's uh head back to our chief
political correspondent John Craig and
certainly um listening to Ali and as we
know Richardson like raised eyebrows in
uh reappointing swella Braven soon after
she had to resign raised eyebrows about
points appointing sir Gavin Williamson
uh for now the reasons we know raised
eyebrows about the decision not to go to
Cobb which he later reversed and then is
about to
um you know give the country tax Rises
and public spending cuts John you know
it's a very difficult first month again
isn't it for for our new prime minister
and add to that last Wednesday we
learned from number 10 that 20 pledges
made by Mr sunac during the uh Tory
leadership campaign all those hustings
in the summer 12 of them uh where
there's going to be a bonfire of the
pledges everything from uh from tax cuts
to health pledges so uh building on the
Green Belt climate issues and so on
we're all completely up in the air so so
uh yes we've had uh U-turn after U-turn
after U-turn from Mr sunac now he will
clearly believe that on this as on other
issues better if something's going wrong
to rectify the mistake than plow on and
plow on and make things worse the famous
uh my famous Dennis Healey phrase when
you're in a whole uh stop digging so
that was as obviously a lot of ministers
always think that better to do a U-turn
and put things right than carry on
making things worse that would be his
thinking obviously
um but uh it'll be another interesting
point is is uh Mr sargavin going to be
replaced quite often when a minister
goes uh the prime minister to show that
he or she's in charge uh announces a
replacement straight away to to show
there's no chaos or crisis in the
government
um if there is no replacement for uh sir
Gavin that will add to the claims of
those MPS who says a non-job and was
only there because uh sir Gavin Mr sunac
wanted him there so we'll see if there
is a replacement
um the suspicion must be that I mean it
and it's more than a suspicion really uh
that he is he was brought into the
government because as a reward for
number crunching uh he was a frequent
visits visitor to uh Rishi sunax
Campaign Headquarters over the week or
so after between Liz truss resigning and
Mr sunac becoming Tory leader he was
clearly closely involved in the campaign
but
having said all that Gavin Williamson
has be attached himself because I've
used that phrase politically to first of
all David Cameron he was David Cameron's
PPS then he became Theresa May's Chief
wit then he became a supporter of Boris
Johnson and of course his critics will
say he helped bring down both
um both uh Theresa May and indeed Boris
Johnson uh because he attached himself
politically to Richie sunac and of
course uh Boris Johnson's supporters
blame Mr sunak's resignation in July for
Mr Johnson's demise so he is a
politician who has moved around in terms
of his political support uh where is he
going to go next I mean there will make
there may be those MPS who fear that
he's going to cause trouble on the back
benches despite what he says in his uh
resignation letter he says right at the
end uh I want to take this opportunity
to offer my full and total support from
the back benches well they always say
that don't they when they're resign you
never hear a a sacked or resigning
Minister say and I'm going to cause real
trouble on the back benches he's
pledging loyalty a lot of MPS will be
waiting to see if that lasts
John would you believe it it was only 14
days ago that Rishi net was was uh was
went to King Charles III I can't believe
it anyway third premises questions as
you said uh possibly Torrid tomorrow we
will watch and wait on that John Craig
thank you very much indeed so the news
tonight this man sir Gavin Williamson
who had already been sacked from the
cabinet on two previous occasions has
quit Rishi sunak's cabinet after
conceding that allegations about his
conduct had become a distraction the
former cabinet office Minister said he
decided to step back from government
while the complaints process into his
conduct is carried out more in Sky News
at 10.
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]